bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo stati su
crede in me non ragazze per i mente
sarebbe per chi mi segue da dall'età
della pietra praticamente avevo fatto un
video su craven manor tipo era ancora la
demo quindi non il gioco completo quindi
ragazzi volevo assolutamente farlo
normale faccia un normale presso giacché
tiro sul monitor di insulti mi di
lasciar perdere un ragazzi l'ultima
volta che l'ho giocato non è una figata
pazzesca anche perché la parte
bellissima la partenza complimenti
quindi se nel caso immediate ma in a
casa così bella da fuori perché non
entrarci dentro
complimenti al protagonismo e sti cazzi
in italia nostro gioco nel mio rigore
era in inglese quando l'avevo giocato
figura ha fatto anche in italiano
fantasma che l'hanno migliorato in casa
eccolo lì il figo regala vi presento
subito al mio amico gli diamo un nome
così ce lo togliamo di mezzo dalla lo
chiamerò ambrogio andrò facciamo
ambrogio cambia un po le luci sta a casa
perché mi odia primi tasto destro per
lanciare un oggetto che stai tenendo in
mano
complimenti comunque parlato non sarà
l'unico a che mi sembra bello da thor
cento gioco si gioca la torcia fa almeno
quello
la libreria e razzista contro i favi j
non ho capito è bella accoglienza di
merda e adesso se non ti dispiace questo
telo menting andiamo avanti lega bello
ovunque come gioco la partenza ci sta
tutta me lo porto dietro così non si sa
mai io dico che mi sembra ha detto altro
complimenti per l'arredamento perché
madonna cos'è unità storia tasto
sinistro del mouse per prendere il mare
questo cos'è ho preso un corso è caduta
la casa fantastico dove me lo porto
questo non lo metto nelle mutande chiedo
come ok mi storico mi sono ricordato i
libri erano sempre stati così prima
guarda ebbe prima che la libreria mi
stupri o uscire da questa stanza grazie
però comunque molto gentile
sono forse successo svenduto cosa intero
che sono stati libri che hanno finto ce
l'hanno control ce l'hanno con me i
libri
buongiorno ma che bella dai seriamente
noi libri hanno chiuso la porta fan dai
ragazzi adesso in avanti il razzismo
contro i libri li brucia a prescindere
tra l'altro non avrò ambrogio a questo
cosa l'ho preso prima quindi lo metto
ecco perché non so neanch'io dove un
mese potrebbe dire per cortesia dove
diavolo è finito ambrogio che stava sul
piedistallo che se anche dimenticato il
mappamondo
io faccio anche i regali alla gente la
gente li lascia per te non faccio più un
cazzo non c'è adesso che ho messo quel
coso praticamente al posto giusto
dovrebbe aprirsi staff infatti morì
cordini non me lo so spiegare
sì però ambrogio ma hai presente che
cos'è una scopa
ecco usala cazzo cioè non è che io posso
sempre che certo quadro che la penna è
un quadro c'è un quadro c'è un quadro
che lampeggia e non è mio quindi te lo
metti
ma che dici se ci faccia se ci facciamo
una bottiglia di vino noi due siamo
buoni amici ascolta membri ginocchio
eccola io io c'ho una bottiglia ti hai
per caso di bere del buon vino insieme
al buon fabi ne vai fuori cioè io ti io
vengo a casa tua ti offro del buon vino
che l'ho portato da casa mia ovviamente
mi tratti così fino perché io torna a
casa
salve hai bevuto troppo io volevo
offrirti dal vino però dove cazzo è
volato il vino
no no no no non si fa no anzi fa la leva
la leva più bravo non lo lascio lì ecco
serviti pure da solo anno fa eco angelo
celo celo dei media di 3 ecco perfetto
comunque l'accoglienza e un'accoglienza
proprio della madonna e compri
complimenti grazie io tornerei a cancun
che ragazzi se per caso togliete
qualcuno a casa vostra
ecco a chi ti chiudo pure le porte di
cache gentleman 36 invitate qualcuno a
casa vostra specialmente fa vj e
invitate di farse cagare che modello
della camera da letto
la metto qua se diceva un seccato su una
donna
io ero troppo brava a fare i puzzle da
piccolo quindi me la cavo che è sta roba
hai una luce azzurro si vede una mazza
il tuo posto quindi mi prende alla
lettera sembra che mi per il culo sto
gioco brava bene di qua ho aperto questo
per me ma ripensandoci torna nella
stanza di prima perfetta ascoltami fra
fratello e non è che possiamo bravo bra
è come vedi già già mi piaci di più non
perché bisogna entrare in simpatia noi
due perché non è che complimenti per il
post io le 1 dvd britney spears più o
meno siamo lì si punta ambrogio ambrogi
senti si può fare un qualcosa di
tranquillo tipo giocare a dama non lo so
di qua dove dove c'è il vino a terra
quello e vino ragazzi non vi spaventate
giorno che c'è un qua a proprio a bra
aprile ambrogio apri sta cazzo di porta
prima che ti lanci una sedia si può
aprire lo scrigno senza che mi spunti
satana dalla ecco mucchio di fotografia
scure sfocate ritraenti sei uomini e
donne nudi si vede che ambrogio non c'è
wifi e al posto di youporn se si adatta
si fa avevo capito pronte ma io non
stava rovistando assolutamente nel tuo
materiale porno
è bravo vai a farti le pippe dove sei
questo è soltanto perché te ne fai un po
troppo mi fa veramente piacere
incontrare ambrogio con la seconda
modello dalla soffitta posso andare
forse grazie molto gentile quindi adesso
dovrebbe esserci al posto di prima
dovrebbe esserci la soffitta quindi qua
dovrebbe essere meraviglioso perché sto
finendo la porta che tanto me la prendo
nel deretano non lo so comunque ragazzi
non so se avete presente se c'è qualcosa
lì sotto io giuro che prende una
scegline bruch al monitor no joe non c'è
nessuno se ti azzardi a monno raga io
non posso vedere se cose negli occhi
cosa cazzo ci avrei scommesso non lo so
ti ammazzo un posacenere tutto ammazzo
con un pozzo a 100 giuro che ti arriva
anche se c'è una leva probabilmente
salterà in aria malatino lo stesso
perché mi piace tirare le leve
ok non è che sono proprio entusiasta di
andare in soffitta bello alla mia camera
la mattina e più in ordine di quei ce ne
vuole
complimenti per la soffitta bellissimo
sport
lo so che chiedo tanto magari che per
caso c'è il wifi
schiaccia scala va benissimo anche un
barile che burlando che sei bravo
ragazzo si è messo dietro il vetro a
caso va beh io vado avanti
questa è casa tua fai quello che vuoi
fai quello che vuoi tema si
possibilmente evitando di lanciarmi
lampadari credo che hitler mi avrebbe
dato un ospitalità migliore di questa è
però non ne sono sicura che è tanto
qualcosa va beh ma ditelo che sono altro
c ma che ne so io ragazzi punta
azzardare a tirare una leva in mia
presenza mai hai capito la stacco e sai
dove tale infilo quando la stacco non
sei già in posizione guarda puoi capirlo
tu stesso mercato mi è caduto meca
allora se glielo raccogliere sono nigro
pare grazie puoi per favore metterti
leaf meter dello ne parla di temi cui si
mi devo fare la strada al contrario
perché sono condizioni stupra c'è ditemi
se è normale
piuttosto che dar tiravano gago e ti do
qualcosa in cambio ma non la mano si
curdo dove posso aprire la porta che sta
dietro di me senza che mi ammazzi ci si
può farlo arati chiudo anche la porta
perché me ne frega na sega ci siamo
ragazzi siamo nella porta bella questa
qui che si è l'ultima spero della stanza
libro libro fasullo cioè soldi
giacché dove devo aprire la porta con la
combinazione proprio l'area che botta di
culo in teoria dovevo metterli in ordine
ma sparati a caso ho vinto va bene così
ancora libri fasulli profeti giorno
ambrogio e risposta mi è già è sparito
perfetta ascoltami una sega
devo trovare la combinazione giusta di
libri praticamente so che questo è
l'ultimo me lo ricordo però non mi
ricordo gli atri lega quindi sono cielo
nel deretano di brutto
ecco che questo primo questo primo
prefetto il prossimo è questo qui no no
no no no no no no non è questo qua
perfetto dove sei ambrogio dove sei
eccola qui che striscia bravo zio passa
vita strisciare che ti ci vedo bene
amico mio ketty ma dice che era un del 3
stella io ero brava sto jacquard ci
proviamo 123 della verso uno due tre
stella
uno due tre stella ammetto che è forte
non detesto la è tutto visto l'avevo
fatta anche nella demo sta cosa di un
due tre stella quindi è veramente
[ __ ]
ma è come faccio io adesso ragazzi
reagan o non è fatto come il diavolo è
possibile una seri di prima va bene sei
molto bravo a striscia al ti auguro di
strisciare per il resto della tua vita
non rompere le balle a me ecco questo no
ti prendo a ski duro che ti prendo a
schiaffi finché non sanguini anche se
sei di legno chiamo chiamo geppetto
piuttosto sei stato adottato
sei stato adottato ok ecco sì sì ho
vinto ma dove di questo vedi questo sai
dove te lo infilo ragazzi soddisfazioni
nella vita proprio questa cosa me la
ricordavo dello schianto è rimasto ma
quanto europa
cosa ti muovi devi morire poi
l'integrale becca un insalata il filetto
di ambrogio velo schiacciato teatro e
che cioè r caio che sta invocando
qualcuno drago cerno 6 tour usa
io non ho visto niente è una roba devo
infilarlo questo cosa è la frase sono a
malissimo però questo è in capo di
bronzo sembra creato per ospitare un
oggetto rotondo di sicuro nel mio culo
quindi prenditi sta merda non lo breve
se l'ho fatta cio fa ecco mi ami
svegliate dove è andato il collo spirito
maligno
ho detto spirito maligno intendevo
fatina delle meraviglie ok
ecco bravo vedete che se si fanno i
complimenti ragazzi agli spiriti tutto
funziona sì però possiamo evitare di
fare sti rumori la minchia comunque
ragazzi la bellezza di sarkozy cosa
ambrogio va beh ma allora facciamo che
il panino lo metto in sconto all'inizio
non perché poi si incazza secondo me
cercava l'impiccato non perché lui si
annoia giocata ma impiccato fa un po di
roba brutta
ok braico continua così è cosa di
minchia sono una leva c'è una legge con
salsicce perché si sposta alessi e
ovviamente io non dormirei ammanco per
il pene in un letto che ha sotto una
scala mai io già so la fobia dei mostri
sotto al letto affanculo fiorenzi c'è
una porta in questa casa poi è
bellissimo complimenti per la scelta non
la condivido ma va bene che è e pensi
mica che rimetto a posto io cosa è
successo ma io l'ho sempre solo sapevo
che erano i libri lo sapete ci avrei
scommesso come usate ti ammazzo la
famiglia mascalzoni di un ambrogio
ascoltami zione che puoi fare che ha già
mi chiami ricordo sapersi
certo adesso sì sì sì ma manco per il
pene che te la faccio e invece la faccio
bene corriamo finché non ci stuprano che
bel gioco di vi piace sozzi bellissimo
cose molto allegre non so cosa li pre
dove sta succedendo basta
sei molto più figo di prima kat offshore
ragazzi che uno qui il video perché sono
diventa un casino comunque lo continuerò
nel prossimo episodio che mi piace un
casino perché avevo già fatto la demo
pista parte più o meno la conoscevo ma
da ora in avanti per eventi e non
conosco quasi una mazza quindi so che mi
chiede
tutti ma quand'è che continui alle isole
show non lo faccio tranquilli adesso 21
davanti sia questo caso la action così
siamo a posto comunque stavo uccidendo
microfono comunque ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagare i facebook e come noi
video tratte descrizione se sì vi siete
ci vediamo al prossimo video band
ragazzi